to our coronavirus coverage tonight
testing has been a challenge for so many
here in the valley battling long lines
and waiting for hours now there's
another big location opening that may
help change that madison kimbrough joins
us live from the fiesta henderson hotel
and casino with more madison
yeah today's turnout was well organized
a nice departure from the chaos that
we've experienced at other location
sites now this testing site is
appointment based only and will be open
saturdays through wednesdays
it's really straightforward really easy
to make an appointment really efficient
new covet 19 testing site arrives at
fiesta henderson hotel and casino and so
far people are happy with how it's
structured this was great actually and
it's i love that they have things set up
in a way that they're just pushing
people through
so there's not a whole horrible wait
time or anything many having to test due
to the surge of omicron at their work my
office said everybody please try to go
get tested sometime this week because
we've had so many cases in the office
one of the biggest reasons for the ease
on the first day was that this
drive-through testing site which takes
place inside of their parking garage is
appointment based only so waiting in a
long line isn't an issue doing the
process online
having the voucher you have to print out
all that stuff it made it super easy and
super efficient in my opinion the sites
will be available for the next 21 days
we're hoping for 4 000
tests per site per day we want to ramp
up to that to kind of meet that demand
of the community
you can register for an appointment by
clicking on this story on our website
and for clarification fiesta henderson
and texas station are offering testing
not vaccines reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now